- On est à la limite
de l'été indien.
Et dans ce quartier
très résidentiel
de Southfields, il y a
cette fumée assez épaisse
qui s'échappe
d'un jardin, avec une odeur vraiment étrange.
Et lorsque
les pompiers arrivent,
ils toquent à la porte
et là, c'est Ouissem Medouni
qui ouvre...
et qui leur dit
que sur son barbecue,
est en train de cuire
un mouton.
(Radio)
Et c'est lorsque les pompiers
veulent éteindre ce feu
qu'ils découvrent
un nez, un pied, une main,
des restes humains.
Sabrina Kouider va arriver
sur les lieux, chez elle,
et va demander :
"Qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
J'ai rien à voir avec tout ça."
(Battements de coeur)
Mais une enquête de voisinage va déterminer
qu'il y avait une jeune fille
au paire, Sophie Lionnet,
qui habitait avec eux
et dont on a, bizarrement,
plus de traces déjà
depuis quelques semaines.
(Musique inquiétante)
(...)
- "Bonjour, Maman.
Je t'envoie un petit coucou
de Londres,
en espérant que ça va
pour tout le monde.
Perso, je vais super bien."
- Le corps d'une jeune Troyenne de vingt-et-un ans
retrouvé calciné à Londres,
en Angleterre.
- Elle s'occupait
des deux enfants
d'un couple franco-algérien.
- "Le manque de la famille
et mes amis
se fait ressentir,
mais sinon, je vais super bien.
- Elle était prisonnière
et n'avait pas d'autres choix
que de subir.
Tout subir, jusqu'à la mort.
- "Je découvre plein
de choses que j'aime.
Mais je vais pas tarder à rentrer, car parfois, je craque.
Et je vais pas faire ma vie
ici non plus.
Big kiss from London, Sophie."
(...)
(Enregistrement en anglais)
(Musique angoissante)
(...)
- En criminologie,
on a des degrés de victimes.
Il y a des victimes
à bas risque, à moyen risque,
à haut risque.
On peut tous être une victime
potentielle de quelqu'un.
- Est-ce que Sophie était
une victime idéale
pour Sabrina ?
Sophie a été la victime
d'une vision,
d'un espèce d'hologramme idéal qui s'est présenté
et lui a promis
une nouvelle vie.
- Je m'appelle Michael.
J'habite à Londres
depuis 42 ans.
La première fois que
j'ai rencontré Sophie,
c'était dans mon restaurant.
Ici, on me connaît comme
patron d'un fish and chips,
le plat typique anglais.
Ici, c'est un quartier plutôt calme, assez huppé.
À Southfields,
y a plein de nounous.
Tous les parents travaillent,
donc ils emploient
des nounous.
J'étais le confident de Sophie.
Même si elle était
plutôt discrète
et qu'elle ne parlait pas beaucoup.
- Sophie est une jeune fille
qui est très calme,
très douce, c'est une rêveuse.
C'est une personne introvertie
qui veut changer de vie,
parce que c'est aussi
de son âge.
Le jour où elle se retrouve
face à Sabrina, que voit-elle ?
Elle voit quelqu'un qui est
radicalement son opposée.
Une femme qui semble,
en apparence, sûre d'elle,
qui est spontanée,
qui est franche,
et tout à fait charmante.
- Sabrina, elle ressemblait
à une super star.
Toujours belle et glamour.
Tout le quartier l'admirait.
Je ne l'ai jamais entendue
élever la voix sur ses enfants.
Quand elle venait me voir,
elle était toujours
charmante et amicale.
- En fait, Sophie était
sous la coupe de Sabrina.
(Musique intrigante)
Ce que Sabrina
veut en public, c'est...
paraître.
C'est quelqu'un de très apprêté,
une personne vue
comme étant
très sympathique et joviale,
donc elle fait attention à ça.
Mais dès qu'elle est
contrariée...
elle peut se montrer
sous un autre jour.
- Ce jour-là,
je m'en rappelle très bien,
Sophie pleurait.
Je lui ai demandé pourquoi.
Elle m'a dit qu'elle avait fait
tomber le beurre...
et que Sabrina l'avait frappée.
- Elle était à bout.
C'était de plus en plus intense.
Le ton montait plus fort.
Elle se ramassait
beaucoup de claques.
- On aurait dit
qu'elle était isolée,
qu'elle ne pouvait pas s'échapper.
- C'est tout le mystère
de ce dossier.
C'est-à-dire que...
Sophie aurait pu partir.
Elle était libre de se déplacer
de la maison à l'extérieur.
Mais elle n'est pas partie.
Peut-être que rentrer,
c'est dire : "J'ai échoué".
(Musique douce)
(...)
- La chambre a
un petit peu changé,
mais j'ai laissé ses affaires.
(...)
J'ai remodulé un peu
sa chambre
pour lui faire un petit mémorial
les jours où je ne peux pas
aller au cimetière.
Sa première photo
à la maternelle
et sa dernière photo au lycée.
(...)
Là, c'était une petite fripouille.
On dirait une petite chipie.
(...)
Cette bague, ils l'ont retirée
du doigt de Sophie...
le jour où son corps
a été retrouvé
dans les cendres.
L'agent policier
me l'a nettoyée.
C'est lui qui l'a retirée,
donc il l'a nettoyée.
Il m'a demandé si je la voulais.
Je lui ai dit : "Oui, je la veux."
C'est tout ce qui me reste
de ma fille, en fin de compte.
(Musique pesante)
(...)
Sophie a toujours eu
la joie de vivre.
Elle aimait jouer, s'amuser,
rigoler, plaisanter...
Elle aimait la musique.
Elle faisait des dessins.
Ado, c'était une personne
très gentille, très sérieuse.
Je dirais qu'elle manquait
un peu de maturité, réservée aussi.
- Elle était adorable.
C'est une fille
que toute copine rêve d'avoir.
Toute copine, oui.
(Elle rit.)
- "À seize ans,
rien n'est compliqué.
Mais rien n'est facile
non plus."
(...)
- Je sais pas si j'en aurais
beaucoup à couvrir comme ça,
mais c'est une histoire
vraiment particulière.
Je dis pas que c'est l'histoire
d'une carrière,
mais c'est une histoire
que tu traites pas à la légère
et qui te poursuit.
Tu touches l'humain aussi.
Tu touches le côté
un peu barjot, quoi,
un peu barré.
(...)
Je suis Willy Billiard, rédacteur
en chef délégué
du journal L'Est-Éclair.
Le quotidien d'une ado ici,
c'est un quotidien
assez calme.
Y a pas une vie culturelle
extrêmement
développée non plus.
Ça tourne beaucoup
autour de l'école,
du collège, du lycée,
essentiellement.
(Sonnerie d'école)
- "Mes vrais amis ont toujours
été là pour moi,
dans les moments de joie
ou difficiles.
Ils sont toujours là
pour faire la fête,
les délires de gamin
qui nous font rire.
Ils se foutent pas de ma tête.
Ne cherchent pas la guerre
ou à juger les autres."
- J'ai rencontré Sophie comme ça.
J'ai pris sa défense
par rapport à une insulte
qu'elle avait reçue.
Elle était là, dans son coin,
elle encaissait...
Et je voyais qu'elle avait
les larmes aux yeux.
Moi, ça m'a rendue
tellement folle
que je suis rentrée
dans la personne, en fait.
Je l'ai frappé, sans le vouloir.
Et c'est comme ça
que notre amitié s'est créée.
Et Sophie m'a présenté
son groupe de copine.
(...)
- On était cinq : moi, Sophie,
Noémie, Perrine et Océane.
Je m'appelle Ophélie
et je connais
Sophie depuis le lycée.
Je connaissais, du coup,
vu qu'elle est... partie.
(Musique douce)
L'entre midi et deux,
on allait dans le bâtiment H.
On discutait de nos galères
amoureuses, enfin...
Le genre de confidences qu'on fait
quand on est adolescentes.
- On se disait tout.
Comment se passaient
les cours...
C'était les garçons, c'était :
"Oh, lui, il me plaît."
Ou "Lui, il me plaît."
Voilà, les trucs comme ça.
- C'était notre confidente,
mais elle avait un peu de mal
à se livrer en retour, à être...
Bah, à se confier à nous
quand quelque chose n'allait pas.
Elle gardait souvent
des choses pour elle.
- Avec moi,
elle était plutôt distante.
Elle parlait, mais...
je dirais que c'était quand même assez difficile.
Je pense qu'elle avait du mal
à parler avec moi
de ce qu'elle pensait,
de ses envies.
(Musique douce)
Mais on avait
un très bon contact,
même si au niveau
des paroles,
y avait pas beaucoup de...
De lien.
- "Que puis-je te dire ?
Et par où commencer ?
Voilà, mon beau-père
a encore
pété les plombs hier soir,
et j'en ai sérieusement marre.
Marre de le voir faire
souffrir ma mère.
Je veux qu'il dégage de chez nous. Ça m'énerve !
C'est bon, là, quoi !"
- J'ai un mari qui avait
tendance à boire.
Et il suffit qu'il y avait
quelque chose qui n'allait pas
pour que tout de suite,
ça éclate.
C'était plutôt des mots...
Euh... que je faisais rien,
que j'étais une incapable.
J'étais une mauvaise mère.
"Tu sais pas faire à manger.
Tu sais pas faire l'amour.
T'es une mauvaise épouse.
Et ta fille, elle fout rien."
(Musique pesante)
- Sophie, c'est une jeune fille
très sensible.
On peut comprendre
que cette jeune fille
qui est plus sensible que les autres puisse être marquée
davantage par un climat familial compliqué
qui peut être potentiellement
violent.
Ça va l'atteindre beaucoup.
Donc elle a besoin d'air frais,
de nouveauté.
Elle a besoin de rêve éveillé.
- "J'ai retrouvé le sourire.
Je profite de nouveau de la vie.
Ce 29 juin 2012 a changé ma vie, et je t'en remercie.
Quand j'étais dans tes bras,
j'étais tellement bien.
Je me sentais protégée."
- C'était son premier petit copain.
Vrai copain, en tout cas.
Ils étaient tendres
l'un envers l'autre,
toujours dans les bras,
à se tenir la main,
à se faire des bisous.
C'était ici qu'ils se retrouvaient
tous les deux le plus.
Applaudissements
(Musique épique)
Elle était libérée,
elle se sentait bien, légère.
Elle se laissait porter
par la glace.
Elle se sentait amoureuse,
aimée, comprise.
In love de lui, quoi.
Je sais pas ce qu'il s'est passé,
mais ça s'est fini.
Donc après, elle a eu du mal
à s'en remettre, je pense.
- “Y a des jours où rien ne va.
Tu déprimes, tu penses
qu'à une chose : le suicide.
Te mutiler les bras.
On dit que la vie est belle...
Si avoir la belle vie, c'est aimer
et te fracasser la gueule après...
- Une fois, j'ai été la voir
dans sa chambre,
et elle pleurait.
Et je lui ai demandé pourquoi.
Et... "Bah, ça va pas.
Je suis pas bien."
"Dis-moi pourquoi.
Je suis là pour toi,
pour te rassurer, tu le sais.
Je suis ta maman."
"Oui, mais je voulais pas
t'embêter avec ça."
Et puis après,
elle a mis ses écouteurs
et elle écoutait ses musiques.
(Mylène Farmer, "Sans contrefaçon")
(...)
- "Voilà,
je vous présente mon idole,
ma mère.
Cette femme fait mon bonheur.
Quand je vais mal,
une chanson
me suffit à me rendre
mon sourire.
Entendre sa putain
de magnifique voix
me redonne le sourire.
Mylène Farmer,
plus qu'une simple chanteuse.
Mon idole, ma vie, ma mère."
- C'était quoi, son rêve,
à Sophie ?
- Son rêve, c'était de pouvoir...
Elle avait beaucoup
de choses en tête.
- Elle écrivait très bien.
Et elle regardait
beaucoup de films.
Elle aurait aimé faire
ce métier-là.
- "Moi, je cherche des castings, des auditions, etc...
N'hésitez pas à me contacter."
- C'est une façon pour elle
d'échapper à son quotidien.
Il est tout à fait normal
dans la vie d'une adolescente
de se projeter,
de visualiser un avenir,
une nouvelle place
dans ce monde.
Mais entre les rêves
qu'elle nourrit
et le contexte dans
lequel elle vit,
il y a un décalage.
- Le cinéma, je lui ai dit
de laisser tomber.
"Toi, tu es quelqu'un de discrète, de renfermée,
pas assez mature.
Pourquoi t'essaies
pas les enfants ?
Tu vois, t'aimes
bien les enfants,
ils viennent tous vers toi."
Elle me dit : “Oui, t'as raison,
pourquoi pas.
(Clocher)
Et un jour, elle m'annonce
qu'elle aurait peut-être trouvé
du travail, mais pas en France.
(...)
C'est à Londres, c'est pour faire nounou au pair.
(Musique douce)
Et quelques jours après,
elle m'a dit : "Je m'en vais."
(Musique pesante)
Et de là, j'étais pas du tout
d'accord avec elle.
Je dis : “T'as tout préparé ?"
“Non, mais je m'en vais
quand même."
On est parties
un petit peu fâchées.
(Musique pesante)
(...)
C'est une image qui me marquera tout le temps.
Tout le temps.
- On va la mettre
à genoux,la filmer.
Et il va y avoir encore
un nouveau déchaînement
de violence.
(Musique inquiétante)
- Donc on est parties
un petit fâchées.
(...)
Elle est partie à pied.
Elle a été jusqu'à la gare.
D'ici, y a pas loin,
y a deux kilomètres.
- Ça m'a pas étonnée quand elle est partie à Londres.
On comprenait
qu'elle voulait changer d'air,
aller découvrir le monde.
Elle était un peu...
Elle aimait l'aventure.
- Sophie, c'est une rêveuse.
Beaucoup de gens
peuvent rêver leur vie
sans passer à l'action.
Et elle, elle a passé
un pacte avec elle-même
qu'elle a respecté.
C'est une jeune fille qui...
Qui a une très forte personnalité, au final.
Ça aurait été bien
que quelqu'un lui dise.
(Musique pesante)
(Un enfant crie de douleur.)
- Yeah.
- "On a mangé
un gratin de pâtes.
Et là, il est 23h15,
donc 00h15 en France.
Et on regarde un film
accompagné de popcorn.
Nous allons à la plage
la semaine prochaine.
- Bah, je la sentais bien, oui.
Qu'elle était plus épanouie,
que son travail
lui plaisait beaucoup.
(Musique inquiétante)
- Sabrina disait
qu'elle travaillait
dans la mode, et quelque part,
Sophie trouve en Sabrina...
une sorte de modèle,
celle qui pourrait lui permettre
de réaliser son rêve.
- Le concept d'emprise,
c'est avoir une vision
de tout ce que fait
la victime,
d'être là à chaque étape.
D'être omniprésent
dans sa tête.
Sabrina a compris que c'était
une jeune fille qui avait besoin
de sortir de son quotidien,
qui aimait l'univers artistique,
et elle lui propose de l'intégrer
dans son monde,
de la maquiller,
d'en faire presque
sa propre fille.
C'est peu probable
qu'à ce moment-là,
Sabrina voulait lui faire du mal.
Le trouble est probablement
arrivé après.
Mais elle a dit les mots qu'une jeune fille de dix-neuf ans
a envie d'entendre.
- Disons qu'au fil du temps,
les nouvelles
se sont estompées.
Je m'inquiétais pas beaucoup
puisqu'elle était là-bas
pour travailler.
Donc moi, je la laissais
à son travail.
- C'était très difficile
à la contacter.
Ça a été très difficile.
- Pourquoi ?
- Pas le temps.
Tout le temps occupée.
Pas le temps.
Elle répondait deux,
trois jours après,
ou une semaine après.
- Elle était débordée.
Elle faisait littéralement
tout à la maison.
Le ménage, la lessive,
les courses.
Je la voyais courir partout,
toute la journée,
des sacs plein les bras.
- A aucun moment,
elle m'a dit :
“Ça va pas.
Je suis mal."
Jamais.
Jamais, jamais, jamais.
- Sophie, c'est quelqu'un
qui cherche avant tout
à rassurer.
Lorsqu'elle dit : "Tout va bien"
à sa maman et à ses amies,
pour que le discours soit cohérent, “Tout va bien",
elle ne veut ni inquiéter
ni s'imposer
dans la vie des autres.
- Un jour, Sophie m'a confié
qu'elle n'avait
jamais été payée.
Je lui ai proposé
de lui payer son billet
pour rentrer en France
et voir ses parents.
Comme
elle n'avait pas d'argent,
je lui ai dit qu'elle me rembourserait plus tard.
Mais elle n'a jamais accepté
cette proposition
qui lui aurait permis
de s'enfuir.
Alors qu'ici,
elle était clairement
traitée comme une esclave.
- Peut-être que Sophie
y croit encore à ce moment-là.
Sauf qu'à un moment,
elle comprend bien.
On le voit dans ses échanges
avec sa maman,
y a quelque chose qui ne va pas du côté de Sabrina.
"Elle m'accuse d'avoir volé
un pendentif...
- Que Sabrina
soit quelqu'un qui,
en apparence,
soit sympathique,
chaleureuse,
loquasse, spontanée,
c'est comme ça
qu'elle est décrite,
n'empêche pas que derrière,
elle peut avoir
une autre personnalité.
(Musique pesante)
Sabrina souffre
d'un trouble paranoïaque.
C'est une femme
qui s'invente des films.
Et elle donne le rôle...
Le rôle de Sophie, c'est quelqu'un de mauvais,
l'ennemie à abattre.
- Sabrina commence à lui reprocher des tas de choses.
Qu'elle sait pas s'occuper
des enfants, cuisiner.
Des brimades,
des accusations,
à se voir traiter
de tous les noms.
- Sophie devient la bête noire
de Sabrina.
C'est l'ennemie
dans sa maison.
Mais au lieu de la faire sortir,
elle la maintient dans son délire de persécution,
ce délire paranoïaque.
(...)
- Un fameux soir,
vers 4h du matin...
j'essaie de la joindre.
Et elle me répond.
(...)
Je lui ai demandé
si les enfants étaient durs,
si c'était cool,
si ses employeurs, ça allait....
Mais elle me répondait
pas franchement.
Comme si elle avait peur.
(...)
Et en fait, son employeur
était à côté, et je l'ai vue.
Et elle entendait
toute notre conversation,
c'est pour ça que
Sophie était souriante.
(...)
- "Si tu me dis pas la vérité,
tu rentres pas en France.
Je vais te pourrir la vie."
- A ce moment-là,
Sabrina est au paroxysme
de son délire envers Sophie.
- "Arrête de mentir, putain !
T'as emmené mon fils, oui ou non ?"
- Sabrina va
reprocher à Sophie
d'avoir emmené son fils
dans une maison où l'attendait
un gros gaillard tatoué
pour abuser sexuellement
de leur fils
avant de le ramener
à la maison.
On va retrouver dix-huit
fichiers audio
sur trois semaines.
A chaque fois,
quelques minutes.
Et ils ont conservé
tous ces enregistrements
sur leur téléphone portable.
- Qui est l'homme
dont parle Sabrina
dans les enregistrements ?
- Mark Walton est le fondateur
de Boyzone.
Un groupe de boys band irlandais dans les années 90
qui a fait fortune.
- From?
- Raheen.
- Y a eu une vraie passion entre Mark Walton
et Sabrina Kouider,
de laquelle naîtra
un petit garçon.
Le couple n'a pas duré longtemps.
Et de fait, elle a commencé
à développer une obsession
envers lui.
Lui reprochant
des tas de choses,
des abus sexuels sur son fils,
sur elle, des violences aussi.
Sabrina Kouider
a très vite été persuadée
que Sophie était quelque part
une agent infiltrée de Mark Walton pour lui nuire.
(Musique pesante)
- Elle souffre d'un trouble.
Elle a un trouble probable
de la personnalité,
ce qui est pas forcément le cas de Ouissem.
Lui, on pourrait dire qu'il a
un trouble délirant induit.
Il suit ce que dit sa compagne.
- Quand on regarde
la structure
des actions de ce couple...
ça fait penser
à la fameuse folie à deux.
On a une personnalité dominante
qui a des croyances qu'elle va
amener tout doucement
à une deuxième personnalité
qui est passive
et qui va être le réceptacle
de toutes ces croyances.
Et d'une pensée unique,
ça va devenir
une pensée commune.
- Et puis, viendra...
cette dernière journée.
Ça fait à peu près
trois semaines
que Sophie n'a plus mangé
à sa faim.
On va la mettre à genoux
et on va la filmer
pour dire : voilà, maintenant,
fais-nous ta confession.
Qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
exactement
avec Mark Walton ?
(Musique angoissante)
- C'est une image
qui me marquera tout le temps.
Tout le temps.
(...)
D'ailleurs, quand je l'ai vue,
j'ai hurlé parce que je...
Ma fille, je la voyais pas comme ça.
On y voyait le visage très creusé...
On voyait tous ses traits.
Je voyais ses mains
très, très amaigries.
De cinquante-quatre kilos,
elle devait passer à être
à trente-cinq kilos.
Trente kilos, quoi...
- Et il s'avère que ça suffit pas.
On va l'emmener
dans la salle de bain.
Et c'est là qu'il va y avoir
un nouveau déchaînement de violence.
On monte encore d'un degré.
Et là, on va tout simplement,
osons le mot,
on va la torturer
en lui mettant la tête sous l'eau,
dans la baignoire.
- C'était un vendredi matin,
en pleine nuit.
Moi, je dors très peu.
Donc j'ai entendu taper à ma porte.
J'ai ouvert la porte
et j'ai tout de suite dit :
"C'est pour Sophie.
Qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ?"
Franchement, j'étais...
bouleversée, peinée,
j'avais envie de hurler.
Mais alors vraiment de hurler,
parce que...
Ma fille s'est vue mourir.
Sous la torture, elle s'est vue
mourir, et ça fait mal.
Ça fait extrêmement mal de voir
ses enfants mourir comme ça.
- Sophie n'a plus respirer.
Ils ont allongé son corps par terre.
Et ils ont fait le choix
de l'enfermer dans une valise.
Et ils ont placé la valise
sous le lit des enfants,
en attendant de trouver une solution
pour savoir que faire du corps.
(Musique pesante)
- Pendant longtemps, je n'arrivais
pas à parler de cette histoire.
Maintenant, ça fait longtemps,
donc je peux vous parler
sans avoir envie de pleurer.
(...)
- Le jour où j'ai appris son décès,
je lui ai envoyé un message.
"S'il te plaît, dis-moi
que c'est pas toi,
dis-moi que..."
Et au final, c'était la vérité.
- Et après cette histoire, qu'est
devenue cette bande de copines ?
- Elle s'est dissoute.
Oui, c'était notre pilier.
C'était une personne en or.
C'était, en tout cas,
une des personnes importantes
dans notre groupe.
- Je l'ai pas assez pris
dans mes bras.
(Musique inquiétante)
Et je le regrette profondément.
Et si c'était à refaire...
Bah, je lui dirais que je l'aime.
Comme je fais avec mes enfants
maintenant, avec mon fils.
Je lui dis constamment
que je l'aime aussi.
(...)
Sous-titrage : BLUE ELEMENTS